A clash at sea causing waves of international
concern.
A Russian military ship rams into a Ukrainian
tugboat off the coast of Crimea.
The vessel was later fired at and captured
by the Russians, along with two other ships
and dozens of Ukrainian seamen, several of
whom were injured.
The United Nations Security Council held an
emergency meeting where western countries
accused Russia of stoking an already deadly
war with Ukraine.
What we witnessed this weekend was another
reckless Russian escalation.
(WB) It is an arrogant act that the international
community must condemn and will never accept."
In response, Russia's representative said
the Ukrainan ship had violated ITS territorial
waters.
Moscow says the incident was a provocation
by Ukrainian president Petro Poroshenko to
boost his support in upcoming elections.
In Kiev, Poroshenko has declared a state of
martial law for 30 days, but insisted it would
not interfere with the looming presidential
vote.
In Brussels, Nato's secretary general warned
Russia that its actions would have consequences.
There is no justification for Russia's use
of military force.
(WB) So we call on Russia to release immediately
the Ukrainan sailors and ships it seized yesterday.
Sea traffic is again flowing through the disputed
waters after Russia briefly blocked the crucial
passage.
But Moscow says it will continue to hold the
Ukrainian ships and sailors while it conducts
its
own investigation.